hey everybody welcome it is a new week
and i have a new microphone and this is
the first uh
first stream with the new mic i changed
it after actually recording today's show
and i'm going to need your help in
figuring out
which elements of audio processing might
need to be
modified um but so far in some tests we
did it's actually sounding pretty good
so i think
we're in pretty good shape it feels very
different it's much more minimal
um from the standpoint of a pop filter
actually i can't reach the old mic so
we'll see
but it's been highly recommended and
i've been told that exactly for the
harshness that i want to
uh eliminate the elements of harshness
from my evre20
um i've been told this could be the mic
for me so
a few other changes i made for people
who care we're doing a little bit
less um gate
and i've also i you know one of the
principles i was given early
in audio engineering which i
know very little about is you want to
boost
the earliest you can in the audio chain
rather than later so as an example
my voice processor had a fair bit
of output gain and from some of the
research i did
oh the s is sharp yes see i have to
that's interesting it's very interesting
you mentioned that because i actually
thought that i needed a slightly
different let me tell me if this is any
better
stephen sucks is that any better to the
s's
anything anything better i didn't change
anything people said it sounded good
before i changed anything
yeah you know it's probably not easy to
do this you know with a slight delay
and all of that stuff in any case um
i'm going to move off of this topic
because i'm realizing with the delay
it doesn't even make any sense to do it
this way
but um you know if actual audio
engineers have any
specific comments then by all means let
me know the signal flow is sure
sm7b into cloud lifter
into dbx voice processor
into mackie okay so that's the uh that's
oh somebody's saying that it's worse
you know what i don't i'm just actually
going to go
uh i'm gonna keep this the way it was
and then just listen to it myself it
doesn't really make sense to take advice
on stream in this way uh okay
is it's raspy or more crisp
interesting yeah i mean why why on earth
would i be asking a live stream so the
audio
the volume level that is certainly a
concern because i am boosting less so
that's actually good
i'm going to do a sl slight tweak
testing testing one two that's getting
me more to the level where i was before
so in any case we'll be uh we'll be
monitoring and doing all sorts of
different things so that's going on now
beyond that
we have uh so many things to go over
with you today
we already have a hype train leaving the
station
on twitch i have six super chats
to talk about um and we are going to
uh hear from donald trump in north
carolina just momentarily here
uh where do i want to start so
unfortunately
it appears as though the
uh trump administration may be starting
to lie just straight up lie
about the number of cases and i hate
that this is the case
but um let me see if i can actually pull
up
these graphics to show you i'm going to
be going over this in detail on
tomorrow's program but i'll just give
you a little bit of a preview let me see
if i can find it here
so this very strange thing happened
let's see if i can
show you this properly the day
that hospitals were told
no longer send your data or data
to the cdc but instead send it to hhs
that was
july 15 16 the day that that happened
lo and behold the seven day moving
average
completely flattened out that's weird
and
jeff hester who has a small youtube
channel he's an astrophysicist he did a
really good analysis of this
and he actually said well hold on a
second let's
look at red states versus blue states
and when you do that you notice let me
pull up my next element here
when you do that you see that on july
16th which is the day that reporting
stopped going to the cdc and started
going to hhs
that day the blue state states won by
hillary
nothing changed there was a slight
uptick in cases in blue states
but in red states the day that the
reporting changed
the cases started going down okay
to understand how unlikely this is first
of all there's the sniff test
the sniff test is did anything change in
red states
such that we would expect this and the
answer is no
number two if things had changed it
takes
you know 10 to 20 days to see the
changes
meaning the real question is did
anything change in red states
uh towards the end of june that would
explain this and the answer is
no and in fact it doesn't pass the sniff
test because it's the red states that
are having
uh increased hospitalization which is a
metric that actually tells us a lot
about what's going on it's the red
states that are having
lower mass compliance etc etc etc so
this stinks to high heaven um
zooming in a little bit let me see if i
can get a different view here
so this is like a zoom in so you can see
the slope in blue states
unchanged when the reporting change
happened on july 16th
and then oh my god red states are seeing
a decline and as we know
you need eight to ten weeks to to really
see a significant decline when your
slope is this
insane it doesn't just flatten out and
go down we've seen it in new york we've
seen it in other places what happens is
it starts to smooth out
instead of seeing you know a 6.8 slope
it would go down to 5
it would go down to 4 and eventually
eventually you would start to see a
decline so unfortunately guys
this stinks to absolutely high heaven i
don't know how else to say it
uh but we now are um very very much
uh dealing with this reality and uh we
we may just not be able to trust the
numbers anymore that's the unfortunate
reality uh okay i have more things to
show you
let me do a couple of super chats if
you're just joining us we are just
supposedly moments from the start of
this press event um
if you were watching on twitch we do
have a level two hype train going right
now
and we have just very powerfully
achieved level three hype train
and it's wild it's wild what's happening
on twitch
over on youtube a few super chats mark
fillion
recognizes that trump is urgently trying
to save his re-election
absolutely lycan rock games says when is
the pacman shapiro debate happening
unclear i don't i mean i'm not aware of
one
dennis says i got a poll call this
weekend i'm so happy that i have to get
something to do
with aggravating this guy a little more
in a few days
okay zachary foster says fauci said
today he's expecting a vaccine by
november but that other treatments are
more likely by next month i would love
to read about that
if anybody has articles on that please
email me because i have not yet seen
that
javi rodriguez says i live in north
carolina the democratic governor and
democratic senate
candidate are all crushing the polls i
think they may help
biden get over the line here yeah i'm
going to have a very uh detailed report
on that tomorrow
excuse me one moment i just need to turn
on the air conditioning
uh i have my nest going here because it
is
very very warm right now very warm we've
got a just a crazy heat wave here
in the new england area 95 degrees
outside but it'll soon be much cooler
in the studio um chris k says he doesn't
hear a difference in my microphone
except it's quieter hopefully we fixed
that jojo rice says if you could go back
in time one year and talk to yourself
what would you say i would say get some
n95 masks
that would be a big message i would send
back to myself
danny thompson says ivanka is here where
i live today bloomington minnesota
allegedly setting up an office for
missing and murdered native american
women
minnesota native american leaders knew
anything about it
and no one knows the exact location scam
yeah i haven't even heard about that but
that doesn't sound
super good we are in the middle of a
level three hype train on twitch thanks
to irie man
jp de beast already exists
annie greenfield sally annette
boy meets mini megahertz q
and of course our old friend dranoa all
of whom have been helping out there
uh yeah our record on hype trains is six
hundred and twenty percent level five
six twenty level five is the most we've
ever had
um i do have a few memes to show people
let me see if i can hold on let me start
closing out some of these things to get
to the memes
i did get memes here we go okay so let
me see
i i just i'll show you guys what i get
sent it's never
i'm not really choosing like the great
stuff or the bad stuff
but i've been sent a bunch of memes
recently this is i don't even get the
reference here but i guess i have been
reminding people about the importance of
voting regularly
wait none of it matters never has
everyone needs to get out and vote in
november okay
i don't totally get that one so that
kind of existential
event i guess um
[Music]
i don't even know what this is about me
i guess taking matters into my own hands
was the gist
are these good i'm not sure so sure um
best place to send memes is david
davidpakman.com
david davidpakman.com um
oh okay this is my stress level based on
what collars do
the base of the pyramid is tulsi i
actually i'm not bothered when people
bring up tulsi it just hasn't happened
in months
someone coughing at me at starbucks now
that can't possibly be true
because i haven't been to a starbucks in
15 years
um so certainly there's no starbucks
stories here
um thank you by the way for the gifted
subs we have we have moved on to a level
four hype train at this point
which is uh insane um
level three has been completed we are on
a level four hype train someone calling
in and mentioning trump
somebody calling in and being
anti-semitic and then of course the top
of the pyramid peak stress is when
someone has a bad
phone connection yeah i mean there's
some some elements here that are okay
but a lot of these are not super precise
but that's an interesting one
um and then i don't even know what tv
show this is from can someone tell me
what this is daddy what was it like in
the before times it's been so long i
don't know i can't even remember your
mother's face
come on it's getting late we need to
find somewhere to rest for the night
this will do for now
what did you find daddy what do those
words mean and then it's the meme it's a
it's a
it's actually like meme inception
memeception where
it's someone looking at the meme of me
saying the only thing that matters is
voting in november
all right i don't so what show is this
this is from the movie the road okay
cormac mccarthy's the road film
adaptation
and someone says it's the walking dead
okay well man i wish i understood the
memes better
and then i have just one other thing to
play for you guys which i think you
might find funny the other day
this is so this this actually is very
very funny
the other day i accidentally clapped i
was just talking and my hands clapped
together
and it sort of startled myself and sarah
wrote to me saying that her mom was
hysterically laughing
when i accidentally clapped and that
they were watching it over and over
again
and they could she couldn't stop
laughing uh let me see the right way to
display this for you hold on
how can we do this here we go
all right let's take a listen to this
let's hope the audio level is good
okay this is me accidentally clapping
and sarah's mom laughing
uncontrollably
now i can tell you guys can't hear that
so let me fix that first
uh okay let's try again on twitter
we have a lot of things to go over with
you today so we're keeping this first
it was so weird i've never accidentally
clapped before
and um it was really really weird let's
look look at it one more time
sarah's mom really liking it
[Music]
all right so there's that um some people
complaining about my microphone i see
that
we are at 80 87 of a level five hype
train which is very very exciting as we
stand by for donald trump
scheduled for the bottom of the hour i
do see a lot of complaints about my new
microphone i think we're just gonna have
to work through it
um i don't know i mean listen we
there's just a lot of different things
going on with the mic i think it sounds
okay
every mic needs to be tweaked and i do
think that it is it has a little bit
less of a
harsh overtone but
um we're going to keep working on it
needless to say we are going to keep
working on it very very much
let me say thank you to john dorsey john
dorsey is new member number one today
at joinpacman.com i very much appreciate
that this is not the only live stream
today at 8 30 pm eastern
tonight i'm going to be streaming with
chess international master levy rosman
we are continuing my training for the
forthcoming pog
champs ii chess tournament so that'll be
tonight
at 8 30 pm eastern time let's see other
super chats as they continue to come in
sunil wani says can you help debunk the
whole deaths from covet not really
coming
covered people to die anyway other ways
of death
thanks for thanks love the content so i
think what you're getting at sunil is
the idea that
there's a conspiracy that oh wow we are
at 110
level 5 hype uh there's a conspiracy
that somebody dies of a car accident
and then it's being counted as a
coronavirus death and it's it's not
happening and people often oh it looks
like we're about to start
people will often try to use that to
argue that the number of coronavirus
deaths is
overstated the reality is it's likely
understated
and uh you know i think we all can tell
the diff oh god operation warp speed
if we you know if someone um
dies of a car accident and they test
positive for coronavirus
that really shouldn't be a coronavirus
death in terms of what we're talking
about
if someone has multiple organ failure
because of coronavirus even though they
didn't
die of the virus the virus caused the
failure
that's a coronavirus death i think we
all essentially understand that
uh okay pair tiran says what does pear
say happy coincident that cdc doesn't
get data anymore what are the odds yes
uh that is exactly what is going on
william bleiseth says
um that's i'm not an expert on
you know 1970s 1950s to 70s argentinian
politics so i am i am no pedonista
myself
but you know i'm not the one to be
giving the history lessons on it
sam crowe says david big fan is it
possible trump actually believes
america's death count is the best and
biden wants to defund the police etc
because that's what his aides are
feeding him you know
it's it's plausible but i don't think
it's particularly likely
i don't think it's it's uh super likely
thanks to zach prakowski uh giving out
subs on twitch like a madman
and we are now at 167 percent
here is donald trump uh i will thank new
members using the coupon co
code july surprise right after this
great to be in this wonderful state so
many friends so much success
and we love being here
and we're here actually today to discuss
the exciting progress that we've
achieved under the operation warp speed
our historic initiative to develop test
manufacture and deliver a vaccine in
record time and that's what it is in
record time
likewise therapeutically we are very
very advanced you're hearing about it
and you'll be hearing about it a lot
more in the next two weeks
we will achieve a victory over the virus
by unleashing america's scientific
genius which is what it is
i'm therefore proud to announce that
this morning
the moderna vaccine has officially
entered phase three already
and that's phase three clinical trials
the final stage
remember this isn't news we this was
scheduled six weeks ago it's not news
of speed nothing even close a second
vaccine is likely to enter phase three
in a matter of days under operation warp
speed
we've shaved years off of the time that
it takes to develop a vaccine
in some cases many years and we've done
it while maintaining the fda gold
standard for safety
this is the fastest a vaccine for a
novel
pathogen has ever gone it's never gone
like this
and if you look at where we are by
phase three we can say evergone by far
four additional promising candidates are
expected to enter
final trials in the coming weeks
including the
novovax vaccine being developed right
here at this facility it's an incredible
facility
we're going to be making a tour in a
little while very
very complete tour yeah trump's hair is
out of focus folks that run it and the
people that operate
we've just completed a tour of
fujifilm's
innovation laboratories and that's going
to be uh done at
much much higher level in a few minutes
after i'm finished and i believe we'll
take a few questions too
which we're carrying out a crucial
bio-manufacturing process needed to make
the novavax vaccine
this production is made possible by my
administration's 1.6 billion dollar
award
to novavax as part of operation warp
speed that lets us deliver
the final product in a time that never
has been achieved anywhere
at any time for anything like this these
same manufacturing processes
are being conducted on an even larger
scale
in college station texas today i'm proud
to announce that hhs has just signed a
265 million dollar contract with the
fujifilm texas
a m innovation center which is quite the
place
to dramatically expand their vaccine
manufacturing capacity
this is weird i want to thank fuji film
ceo martin meeson
for welcoming us today and is he not
talking about fujifilm like
am i the one who's wrong and he's
talking about fujifilm
to be with you under these circumstances
in particular with all the progress
that's being made
as well as novovac ceo stanley eric
stanley thank you very much thank you
very much for being here
thanks also to secretary alex azar who
is with us
senator tom tillis thank you very much
he's going down
good job you've done thank you very much
representatives richard hudson david
rouser
mark walker dan bishop and greg
murphy thank you all friends all
warriors
lieutenant governor dan forest who i
hear is doing a great job where's dan
stand up dan
great job dan really good north carolina
house speaker tim
moore thank you tim great job
and president pro tem of the north
carolina state senate
phil berger thank you phil very much i
appreciate it
operation warp speed is funding a
historic portfolio of highly promising
vaccine candidates
in addition to our 1.6 billion dollar
investment in novofax
we've issued a 483 million dollar
contract with
moderna a 1.2 billion dollar contract
with astrazeneca
a 465 million dollar contract with
jansen and just last week a 1.95 billion
dollar agreement
with pfizer tremendous progress is being
made with all of those
kaiser great companies a groundbreaking
agreement with pfizer includes a
guarantee to deliver 100 million doses
shortly after the vaccine's approval
almost
immediately with the option to purchase
an additional 500 million thereafter
not only is operation warp speed
accelerating the development of a
vaccine
we're also directing a colossal
industrial mobilization to ensure its
rapid
delivery nothing's happened like this
since the end of world war
ii starting to swell instead of the
usual sequence of vaccine development
testing and trials
followed by production our strategy is
to conduct these
phases simultaneously so everything goes
at one time
we're not waiting and waiting and
waiting it's all going at one time
we have a system that has anyone else
noticing
a dent to the right of his right eye
it's going to work and work very well
we're mass producing all of the most
promising vaccine candidates in advance
so that on the day one that it's
approved
it'll be available to the american
people immediately and will probably
have a lot for
a lot of other people throughout the
world the world is suffering from this
giant virus another dimension of
operation warp speed is our focus on
therapeutics to treat the virus
over 140 clinical trials are underway
and a number of effective therapies have
already been developed and widely
delivered
including rem de severe which is having
a tremendous impact you see that with
mortality rates and
other things statistically it's having
dexamethasone
convalescent plasma plus and antibody
treatment i've been waiting for that for
months
numerous treatments right now that are
under study and i think over the next
couple of weeks we may actually have
some very positive
answers as to that on july 7th we
announced a 450 million dollar agreement
with regeneron to begin advanced
manufacturing of its antibody treatment
which is currently
in late stage clinical trials lately
best about that is it's been months
since he mispronounced it and now
now he's back to plasma in our increased
knowledge and how to treat the virus
the mortality rate for patients over the
age of 18
is 85 percent lower than it was in april
think of that 85 percent
and is 25 lower than europe as a whole
in the middle of april more than 22
percent of all deaths in the united
states were attributable to the china
virus
as the last week that number has dropped
down as of last week it's dropped down
to
under seven percent to decrease the
turnaround times for testing the first
two laboratories have been approved to
provide
pooled testing very important in other
words
samples from multiple patients are
processed together they're pooled oh
now pool testing will reduce turnaround
times by
more than substantially more than 50
percent
last week our centers for medicare and
medicaid services began
distributing rapid point-of-care
diagnostic test instruments
to all of the nursing homes in the
united states
focusing on the areas of greatest need
which is our
elderly and our nursing homes what we've
already sent includes testing
instruments to
635 nursing homes for 196
000 rapid point-of-care tests it's a
tremendous amount that's
you'll get your response and answer from
five to 15 minutes
over the next three weeks 1 700 nursing
homes will receive an additional eight
hundred thousand
point of care tests think of that the
united states has conducted over 52
million tests
that's more than all of europe put
together times two
nobody's even close and as countries go
no
it is uh as an example india
is up to 11 million tests we're going to
be very shortly at 55 million tests
india has 1.4 billion people
through our relentless efforts we've
completely rebuilt up notice he chooses
india which is a disaster on coronavirus
pleaded and did not refill the cupboards
were bare
i say it often in total still wrong
we've now distributed nearly 100 million
n95 masks
35 million surgical masks imagine
being president for three years with
supposed bear cupboards
and then during the three years which
you do nothing you then blame the
previous guy
now building thousands a month and would
distribute him
we have all we need in our country but
to other countries that are in desperate
need
other countries are having a
tremendously difficult time with the
virus last week fema sent additional
personnel
protective equipment to over 15 000
nursing homes including 643 000
pairs of protective eyewear 7 million
masks
34 million pairs of gloves and 6 million
gallons
over the weekend cases in florida texas
and arizona held steady and
are now heading down in arizona they're
heading very substantially
it does appear as though they are they
are now suppressing the data i'll have a
full report tomorrow
states and are surging them resources
when requested they largely had what
they needed but anything they need we
send
them immediately we are totally full we
have everything we need we get it to the
states immediately we deal with the
governors
the relationship with the governors he
didn't list how many schwabs they sent
out though
goods but rigorous compliance with
guidelines should allow them to
turn the corner and very very quickly we
are
working with every governor and health
commissioner across the country to bring
a complete
individualized analysis to each state as
well as tailored
recommendations states are different my
administration is also closely
monitoring the
surging caseload in latin america
which is now the region in the world
with the most active reported infections
this is trump pretending like we have
the resources to actually deal with
what's going on in other countries when
things are completely out of control
here
cases is also likely to be
dramatically undercut or undercounted
and i can say that's probably true
throughout the entire world
we report our cases most of the world
doesn't they either don't do testing
therefore they have very few cases even
though people are sick
or they just don't report exactly what's
happening here reality of what we just
said
we're focusing aggressively on the texas
border and
countries that we think have to be
watched very very carefully because
you have some very very highly infected
countries
outside of this one our borders i've
spoken with governor
abbott terrific gentleman and i can
report that over 3
300 federal personnel on the ground in
texas we've
given them a tremendous amount amount of
extra help including doctors
nurses frontline people they sent plots
we've supplied texas with more than 2.5
million gloves
800 000 goggles 336
000 surgical gowns 1.8 million surgical
masks
1.36 million n95 respirators and half a
million
k and 90 masks beginning this week texas
hospitals will receive 500 cases of
rem de severe which has proven very
effective
enough to treat 3200 patients
in addition to the cross-border spread
the stage of the pandemic is being
fueled by younger americans who
generally have little risk of being
seriously harmed by the disease
but can spread the disease we need all
americans to be conscious about their
actions and to exercise
extreme vigilance i trust all americans
imagine the gall
after one of the worst five responses in
the world to come up and talk about how
soon we'll be able to help really
infected countries who don't know what
they're doing like it's it's
just stunning that this is what's going
on this guy deserves never to work again
cars and wear masks when appropriate
we also strongly urge citizens to take
extra precautions to shield those
at highest risk which are in most cases
in many cases the elderly especially the
elderly with medical problems such as
heart
or diabetes but you want to shield them
and you want to guard them and you want
to protect them from the virus
especially
especially those that are really
targeted almost targeted you could say
by this horrible
horrible plague this horrible epidemic
pandemic america will develop a vaccine
very soon and we will defeat the virus
we will have it delivered in record time
as our visit here demonstrates and i
want to thank all of the people and
representatives from the great state
of north carolina there's a great
there's a great place
it's a phenomenal place and uh which you
may lose
we've had so many great meetings and
such a great time
i want to drive and to drive in tenacity
of
your representatives and your
politicians has been incredible
when they call i'm there when they call
most of them many of them are sitting
here right now
i will always answer their call right so
thank you very much i appreciate you
being here with us
and let's get on to a few questions
tremendous
progress has been made and it's been
made rapidly and it's been made in areas
here's some nasty questions nothing like
that has taken place before
so please thank you very much imagine
clapping for that
thank you thank you
there's been a lot of despair when it
comes to the virus is today's event
about giving americans uh hope
a sense of optimism is that what you're
trying to well i think
i think so but you know there would be
not that same kind of hope if we weren't
doing so well
right you know before just before i left
the white house in the oval office we
had a meeting with our
doctors scientists some others and
they're making tremendous
progress with respect to uh therapeutics
i can tell you therapeutically i think
over the next couple of weeks we'll have
some really very good things to say
we're just having great answers so it is
about that
and it's also the vaccine that we
discussed today at even greater length
is just coming along really well they're
going great and it's not just one
company as
many companies have had tremendous
progress so that'll be announced over
the next very short period
well i heard very positive things but by
the end of the year we think we're in
very good shape to be doing that by the
end of this year we're going to
in terms of the vaccine i think in terms
of therapeutics even sooner than that
especially therapeutics meaning you go
and you give somebody whether it's
transfusion or
shots or whatever it may be and they
heal
and they heal quickly so we've had
tremendous progress we already have if
you look at
rem de severe from december you look at
some of the other things
but we'll have we'll have some
announcements on that over the next two
weeks yeah
it is hope but it's only hope because
we've gotten
such incredible results scientifically
you did talk with russian president
vladimir putin and
i wanted to ask if you did bring up the
reports
of russia having bounties on
our soldiers and beautiful we don't talk
about what we discussed but we had
plenty of discussions
whatever happened to that story earlier
today said that uh the v-shape recovery
is showing signs of moderating
do you think given what we're seeing
with the increase in cases that the
recovery could be in jeopardy at all the
economic
i don't think so i think the recovery
has been very strong we've set record
job numbers we've set record numbers
whether it's a prv or a little bit less
than that
i think it's going to be very good if
therapeutically we
come up with some answers very quickly
which i think we will
then you're going to have a tremendous
recovery
likewise with the vaccines if you do
that by the end of the year that's ahead
of schedule substantially ahead of
schedule
and it's ahead of anything that's ever
taken place in terms of vaccines before
so i think if those things happen if
just one of those events happen
you'll go right back into that v and i
think you're probably in the v
anyway i really do believe a lot of the
governors
should be opening up states that they're
not opening
and we'll see what happens with them but
a lot will have to do with the fact that
therapeutically i think you can have
some great answers vaccine wise
likewise yeah please go ahead in the
back asking zachary eads from the
raleigh news and observer
now that you've cancelled the
jacksonville portion of the rnc
do you think governor cooper made the
right choice in limiting
attendance in charlotte well we're
actually coming to
north carolina as you know we're having
a very major i guess that would be the
nomination
night so that's monday that'll be monday
they're going to be here
and the rest will do in a different form
we could have
uh done it many different ways but i
think we did the right thing and
uh i'm really happy that we're going to
be having a piece of it at least and a
very important piece
in north carolina yes please go ahead mr
president your poll number
suffered in recent months because of
your handling on the pandemic they're
here now today
what's your plan going forward to prove
to americans that you're the right
person
i think the poll numbers are very good
uh the poll numbers we have are very
good we're leading in north carolina
we're leading in pennsylvania we're
leading in arizona
all lives we're leading in arizona we're
leading nicely in florida i think our
poll numbers are very good
we're leading substantially in georgia i
mean
uh we get a lot of suppression polls we
get a lot of fake polls just like we
have fake news i mean it's a terrible
thing
when you look at it but i had the same
thing four years ago i was losing
everywhere i had poll numbers where i
wasn't going to win any state and i
ended up winning every one of them
that that's so unknown true the swing
states
crazy thing to say and i have the same
thing
this year this year they have it even
closer they have it closer but
no no not true suppression type polls
we have polls that show me leading in
almost every swing state
and substantially in other states
by even more than a 1 in 16. when you
look at florida as an example
you have thousands of boat out about
boats out of the ocean out of the
intercoastal
you look at other states where likewise
you have thousands of
boats and they're all waving the trump
sign
trump pence sign and they're so proud
thousands and thousands you've seen it
well you have bikers for trump with
lines that are miles long on highways
going along
on weekends i think there's more spirit
now
than there's ever been okay for my
campaign i don't mind him
saying this because hopefully it'll
placate the trumpet so they'll be like
he's winning i don't have to go and vote
i think there's more today because what
we've done nobody's ever done before
nobody has ever rebuilt the military
cut taxes the most in our history
created the greatest economy we've ever
had
cut regulations at a level that nobody
has ever depression that's a gene and
all of these different things the va we
got va choice that's an obama policy
trump's most regularly touted
accomplishment is va choice which is an
obama policy from 2014.
just speaking to the secretary 91
percent in the via that's never happened
before
uh i think when people see all that
we've done even space force
we created a force a actual
you know army navy air force marines
right it's
it's pretty amazing coast guard and now
space force that hasn't happened in 75
years
uh what we've done working with some of
those warriors over there by the way but
what we've done
has never been done if you look at
alaska with anwr one of the bill
perhaps the biggest drilling site in the
world even ronald reagan and bush
and clint everybody wanted to get it
done i got it done anwar and alaska
probably or possibly the biggest
drilling site in the world
no what we've done has been incredible
recently
it looked like the energy business was
going to be
a catastrophe we were number one in the
world and then we had the pandemic and
nobody was using energy nobody was
driving in automobiles
no gasoline and by the way gasoline
prices for everyone are very very low
what does it mean to be number one in
energy that's pretty incredible
and i saved the energy business i got
russia and i got saudi arabia on the
phone
i don't remember the question either but
now at forty dollars and
plus a barrel and we're saving tens of
millions of jobs and energy
we're the number one in energy in the
world so with all that we've done
saving tens of millions of energy jobs
that that doesn't add up
right guys that makes no sense had an
economy like we had prior to the china
plague or china virus coming in we never
had numbers like it
we are going to have them again and
everyone knows i'm going to rebuild it
i had to close it up we saved millions
of lives by closing it if we didn't
close it you would have seen numbers
that would have been
uh this is a verbal ink blot what you
have right now one death is too much
but it would have been 10 to 15 times
maybe more than that what you have
we closed this greatest economy ever far
bigger than china better than china
china was having by the way the worst
year they had in 67 years tariffs
they paid us tens of billions of dollars
remember our businesses pay the tariffs
when we import the stuff from do
you guys know being the best year we've
ever had i had to close it
and now we're reopening it and next year
we'll be stronger it'll be the strongest
year so far
it'll be better even than last year okay
thank you very much i'll be heading back
and i'll see you back at the white house
oh my god what an absolute tour
of the facility with your great leaders
uh thank you very much to the people of
north carolina we love being here thank
you wow
what an absolute disaster i mean a
verbal inkblot a complete and total joke
um before people go by the way
if just a few of the people watching on
youtube hit subscribe
we could get to 900 000 subscribers
right now on youtube we're only 2 800
away there's 20k
people watching okay if before you leave
you can hit that subscribe button it's
free
we could do 900k right now which is i
mean once we
that's the last milestone before a
million okay
insane so please if you are heading out
now because you didn't really want to
see me here anyway
um please please do hit that subscribe
button
um uh before you head out and it would
it would be i mean we could we could
literally get to 900
000 right now uh okay um
i do want to mention that a few people
have signed up on my website during this
and i want to make sure everybody gets a
thank you as you know
we're mostly funded by website
memberships the the two streams today
and the podcast and the youtube clips
you know all the stuff
joinpakman.com coupon code is right
there 20 20 now
we had one person sign up before the
stream
i do want to say thanks to wendy summers
who is new member number two today
uh and lynese james who is new member
number
three and that coupon code above my head
does
save you two-thirds we're not talking
about a lot of money
we've you know taken some hits due to
coronavirus and the financial crisis
that is of course
hitting a lot of people so if you do
like what we do and honestly even if you
don't but you think it's important
um we do have some supporters who are on
the right
grab a membership at joinpackman.com
um you might have missed earlier i went
through in detail
the coincidence that the day that the
trump administration
said hey don't report your cases to the
cdc anymore
report them to trump's hhs
case is immediately flattened okay and
there is every reason to believe right
now that we are starting to simply get
false data from the trump administration
and we had anecdotal reports of it early
on oh
florida says you might they might be
suppressing death tolls or whatever
they have now said straight up to
hospitals don't send your data to the
cdc send it to hhs
and lo and behold that exact same day
we see a flattening of cases and in
particular the cases have flattened in
the red
states i just don't believe it at this
point in time uh
it's possible listen if they're doing
this with cases they will do it with
deaths
and as you can see immediately you know
i believe it's likely
florida currently has 14 to 16 000 new
cases a day
they're more around these numbers and i
simply don't believe it we've not seen
any evidence that you can turn the
numbers around that quickly
new york couldn't do it with strict
guidelines i just don't believe it
so i think we are now being given
complete and total
bogus bogus bogus bogus information
uh plain and simple tonight
the next stream tonight is at 8 30 p.m
eastern time
i will be coached it's going to be a
non-political stream i will be coached
by international chess master levy
rosman
continuing my preparation for pog
champs 2 which is going to be
extremely exciting i want to say thanks
to
shantel white who is new member number 4
today
on my website also tyler
dunnishaw dungeon is new member number
five today which i very much appreciate
i will
name everybody else on tonight's stream
other than
marie wetherington who is new member
number
six thanks for joining me if you're an
actual audio person
let me know what tweaks i should make to
the new microphone
and i'll be back with you in just a few
hours
you